hello everyone and welcome back to the
last leg of the feeder Grand Prix it's
Dimitri under 18 versus Maxine Rochelle
a grove and raking defeated in the first
round he defeated shocker mama Dee are
off and the Maxine Marshall across the
field Veselin Topalov so the two of the
classical games between the two of them
have been drawn and this is the first
game of the rapids and Ragan has the
white pieces and we do have a nice photo
of this matchup
there you have it under 18 celebrating
his a great position over maxi Marshall
a graph or maybe or maybe he isn't we'll
just have to wait and see also the photo
is a courtesy of official photographer
Nikki Riga so there you have it
and now let's enjoy the game under akin
with the white pieces opened with e4 we
have c5 Maxine of course goes for his
Sicilian defense we have nice to see
three and they can goes for the close
Sicilian and now d6 we have Knight gt2
and not nice to f6 with H 3 and E 5 now
so really a closed position and d3 there
is one game in the database where g3 was
played but with the d3 we have a
completely new game as of move five so
with Knight to c6 by Emil he continues
development in the g4 now preparing to
dislodge at night with g5 Bishop d7
mvl is not bothered by that with rush of
the g2 and now H 5 so we have g5
advancing the pawn nice to h7 putting
pressure on g5 and now h4 are just
cementing that g5 point and now you
could continue this game in a variety of
ways for example you could transfer the
night to f8 and then perhaps I go to g6
or East X depending on what y place but
mvl immediately strikes in the center
with f6 now is this one of the positions
where it's okay to actually play f6 will
also have to wait and see so night the
d5 centralizing the night making room
for the other night on c3f capture some
g5 with H captors and g5 and the night
captures and g5 so MVL grabs a pawn here
and now Knight to c3 and Reagan says
that his setup in the center is well
worth the sacrifice pawn so jisuk
as the age five point is hanging and now
comes night characters on e7 we have
Queen captures on e7 and and ninth to b5
now the other night takes takes the
place of the previous night Queen back
to DA - you have to guard the c7 square
and now f4 so you could go for each
captures an f4 if Bishop captures get
your Knight to e5 have a very very
strong Knight set up here now and then
for example if characters captures you
get this position where it's a it's a
pretty nice position black has a variety
of ways to play this you can throw out
the Bishop to g4 you can go nighty six
to f4 as f4 is nicely covered once you
maybe Castle or just bring the rook over
to f8 so it is possible now but MVL
decides to go for knife to f7 which
allows an under akin to advance the pawn
further so f5 will G captures on f5
which weakens the h5 pawn he captures on
f5 and not nice to d4 and here for some
reason
well not for some reason it's hard to
decide for on such a move but Bishop the
e3 is played
you don't under content one this night
here on d4 where it can target the c2
pawn because if you play something like
rook captures on h5 rook captures and
Queen captures now you're not gonna go
after the C to pawn because there's
simply too much pressure around the
black King you're gonna have to go back
with Knight captures on f5 and the white
will be much better here but it's hard
to decide for something like that in
wrap your game if you go for Knight
captures on c2 then just King d1 you
attack the knight and now if you go
after the rook well now you just get
Queen to g6 and it's gonna be yeah Queen
g6 or Queen to h7 is just gonna be a
very hard position to play for for black
so it's just move it the knight being
able to come to f6 you can push f6 you
can go Queen g8 check its it will be a
completely winning position for white
however also brush up to h6 if the King
tries to block the Queen's entrance the
g8 is possible so it's definitely the
way to go
rook captures an h5 but it's a rapid
game you don't really have time to
calculate what happens after all the
trades and Knight captures and c2 so
Bishop to e3 and Reagan wants to
eliminate the night
from d4 and now Bishop captures an f5 by
Maxine with bushel characters on d4 and
now not recapturing immediately but
first Bishop to g4 just a nice efficient
- with an attack on the Queen Bishop to
f3 and now see captures on d4
eliminating the piece now and here
c4 it seems like you can grab some
initiative with Bishop captures on g4
but black will not recapture right away
because first Queen to a5 check is
coming which connects with the attack on
the knight on d5 and now after c3 now
you capture the bishop if captures
captures now white doesn't have time to
create anything here because the knight
is under attack you would have to first
deal with that Queen goes here now you
can Castle queenside and everything is
perfectly fine for black so you don't
have this first see for now the knight
is nicely protected by ship kappa % g4
definitely is a threat but now D
characters and c3 on pass on will be
captures on c3 and Queen to a5 now
putting pressure on the night here so if
you capture the bishop just Queen
captures on d5 we look the b1 by and
rake in going after the b7 pawn but now
just Knight the g5 here putting more
pressure on the f3 Bishop and here what
you want to play is Bishop captures on
g4 and now allow Queen captures on d5
which comes with an attack on the rook
on h1 but now Queen the a4 with Czech
Queen and now you have to block with the
Queen if you play something like king of
727 then Queen to d7 is very strong it
nicely connects with the bishop on g4 so
here you would have to play some like
win ce6 trade Queens and continue with
this endgame in in some way let's say
would be 7 you cannot capture the bishop
because the rook hangs but now look h7
black has this is disposal now you
capture on h5 with checking d8 and now
you continue playing this game you're
down upon but you your pieces are nicely
placed so it should be should be very
much playable so after this Knight to g5
Bishop captures in g4 is best for under
18 but he goes for Knight to f6 check so
King to f7 putting pressure on the night
here and now you have problems because
if Knight
actress Angie 4-h captures you get
Bishop captures on b7 first you have to
keep an eye on the rook on h1 so after
rook captures on h1 bunch of characters
on each one you get rook 288 and now
your bishop is under attack if rook to
b7 check you just move the king and now
there are too many threats this is a
threat Knight to f3 will be a threat in
some light rock a force on h1 is a
threat and here our black is just
completely winning so it's impossible to
go for this we have castles now putting
the rook on the same file as the king so
it's not a problem you don't lose the
piece maxime before grabbing the night
goes the knight to the h3 check King h1
and now King captures on f6 we have
Bishop captures and g4 would have
discovered to check winning back the
piece now comes the knight back to f4
just blocking trick Bishop to f3 getting
the bishop out of harm's away and now
rook a to g8 and now it's gonna be very
hard for for what a white to defend this
with the black rooks being so active
with rook captures and b7 with ideas of
Queen to b3 followed by Queen to f7 but
rook to g3 now and already there are
some very unpleasant threats here now
like well if you just bring this rock
over for example to g8 rook to h3 will
be made so Queen to b3 like I said with
the idea of reaching f7 so now location
3 followed by rook to G it is impossible
because the Queen also covers the g8
square
so first rook the f8 here Maxine blocks
it and now d4 so what do you play here
yes what is a threatening to open up the
position in front of your king but there
is still time
Queen h6 you threaten the rook on f1 and
here how do you play this c4 was played
by by Andre can but this doesn't work
because c4 prevents the White Queen from
reaching a very specific square that we
already mentioned so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find why well
not why but the best winning winning
idea for black well I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on paying attention
yes
when c-4 was played the Queen no longer
guards the g8 square so rook to h3 is
the move but you have to look a little
bit further King did you want now rogue
g8 check King the f2 and now Maxime that
goes for the very nice rook to g2 check
now if Bishop captures of course you
lose the Queen on b3 so King the e1 was
played but now Queen to a5 with check
now you cannot move the King if you move
the King just Queen d2 is made so look
the b4 was played but now maxime just
played rook captures an a2 and it was in
this position unmoved 36 that Dmitri and
vacant resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here rook to a1
check is coming
whatever you do let's say Queen c3
you're still gonna play rook e1 check
and after the King moves now look the h2
check King g1 and now just Queen to a 2
and there is no good defense against
Queen to f2 mate the rook will not be
able to capture because the rook is
pinned and you don't really have any
other yeah you could prolong it a bit
with check but just King g5 black is
gonna ignore you and if Queen e3 in
preventing Queen f2 mate then it just
get rook to g2 with check King to h1 and
rook captures on f1 with Czech Queen has
the block and now either rook in capture
and it will be made so of course this is
only one of the lines but under a key
knows that that is over so that he
resigns on move 36 so that's the game
the first game of the rapid tie breaks
between the two of them that finished
and the other game of the rapid ended in
a draw so in VL ghost the advances to
the higher parts of the tournament
under 18 is eliminated from the
competition and MV l will meet Jana pony
she who he will have to beat if he wants
to grab a spot in the candidates
tournament so that's probably the next
game we're gonna cover so you know hope
you will be ready for that so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank a walker of the
ground
Tom Tom Petri Daniel Silverberg Toby
Nelson and the Nicholas Durov Algar now
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
soon continuing the coverage of the Fida
Grand Prix continue to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world and of course
do be a part of the subscribers video
it's going to be awesome so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day